well a big seller this holiday season is
michael bolton's christmas album this is
the time happy birthday jesus hope you
like crap
oh geez
i hope you're having a good holidays
it's still going on it's crazy
the holidays it all just started as one
guy's birthday
it was just one guy's birthday and it
turned into a whole season kind of makes
you wonder if like when jesus was alive
if he was one of those friends that was
like hey i just want to give you a heads
up my birthday's coming up so
i mean you don't have to do anything you
know
but if you want to chop down a tree and
put in your living room that'll be cool
yeah
you could recreate my burst scene with
dolls if you wanted
no what if you got friends and you just
sing songs door to door that'll be all
right i don't want you to overdo it yeah
definitely celebrate the night before my
birthday you know i was like it's the
night before his birthday
why don't we go for 12 days let's go for
12 days
and then just end the year i just want
people in january to be like i'm still
recovering from jesus's birthday
that was insane
jesus's birthday celebration makes all
of their birthday celebrations pale in
comparison
i remember when my daughter turned six
my wife threw this amazing party for her
and after the party my daughter was like
that was the best birthday ever and i
had to tell her i was like oh sweetie
that was nothing
compared to jesus's i mean your birthday
was lame
and she was upset but it was a teachable
moment
some people are sad around the holidays
that's gotta be hard for jesus right i
hate christmas
she's like oh that that's my birthday
then i hate your birthday oh well then
you're going to
hell i thought you forgave everyone it's
my birthday
and you ruined it by the way that's how
jesus sounds a lot of people don't know
that
it's a very gentle tone
my brother mike was born on december
25th and he is nothing like jesus
nothing and growing up he would complain
he felt ripped off because he had to
share his birthday
with god's son
oh
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
i was talking to my friend the other day
about jesus
uh christ and um
i don't remember why but i happened to
mention that jesus was jewish
and my friend said he was
and i said yeah jesus was jewish
and he said i don't think so
and i said that's okay it already all
happened doesn't matter what you think
but he argued with me he was like dude
jesus couldn't be jewish think about it
i'm like you [ __ ] think about it you
idiot
what did what was he then in europe
was he presbyterian what was he
catholic
okay jesus was catholic
and he had a gold chain with a cross
and when they nailed him up he was like
oh that's why we have those
that finally makes sense i didn't even
know
oh [ __ ] that's me i'm the little guy on
it
every religion has a strange story or a
rule that doesn't make sense to me you
know like every time there's a terrorist
act they always tell you uh on the news
about how they believe they're all going
to uh heaven and every guy who does a
jihad thing
and he gets 72 virgins that's right
that's that's the story always 72
virgins which first of all who are those
women
who are the 72 virgins does god have to
kill 72 nice girls
all right ladies uh
the good news is you're going to heaven
the weird news
or does god just make him fresh like
farm-raised salmon he just
and whips up 72 women all right nobody
[ __ ] these i'm saving them for that guy
it's a weird concept you get your own 72
virgins for all eternity first of all
they're only virgins when you first get
them
once you start [ __ ] him it's over
after a week he's like i only have three
left
and 69 [ __ ]
that has to be one of the more confusing
moments in god's life when he's handing
off 72 virgins to some guy who just blew
up a bus in tel aviv
and he's like all right
what the [ __ ] am i doing i don't even
know anymore
i need a drink
oh jesus everyone in humanity's history
has been over some kind of [ __ ]
religion
you know i mean i don't get caught up in
that [ __ ] because i don't think god
ever wrote a bible or quran he didn't
have to write no [ __ ] he ain't no play
right
it's written in your essence
because the bible is written by men the
book of peter the book of john
the whole book about jesus but that
[ __ ] ain't wrote one book
do a [ __ ] that is about getting
right [ __ ]
all the hangouts wrote the book [ __ ] i
know the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you noticing each one of them booked
they the closest one to jesus peter like
me and jesus was tight
in john's book y'all damn near the [ __ ]
daddy you know
god didn't write no book
it's written in your essence
nobody ever had to tell you it's wrong
to kill your mama
somehow you born innately knowing that
which means you born knowing right and
wrong so put the book down because it
will [ __ ] you up
you understand me
it starts out messed up in the beginning
in the book of genesis in the beginning
there was adam and eve
and adam and eve had two sons cain and
abel and cain and abel got married
to who
where did these mystery [ __ ] come
from
i like messing with christians but
because they easy to get you can get on
their skin quick you know
telling me jesus died on the cross i
don't buy it
jesus could feed a thousand with a loaf
of bread walk on water raise the dead
you telling me he couldn't handle three
nails
i know brothers with nine bullet bones
still walking around
his name is 50.
[Applause]
i bet you jesus was a cool kid his mama
be like now jesus go on in there and
take a bath and don't be walking on your
water
[Music]
[Applause]
that's probably why they invented the
shower just to get the [ __ ] wet
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally this christmas santa claus
will be starting a new look
at up-to-date shopping malls around the
country they will now feature black
santas asian santas hispanic santas and
even middle eastern santas it is all
part of a program to make little
children cry
oh jesus i read the bible a lot and i
was reading you know somebody got to
back me up on this so you don't think i
made it up for the sake of the joke
how many people know jesus had little
brother
right anybody know his name what's his
name
james
i was reading that i was like wow
how much pressure was that
jesus your big brother
how many times do you have to hear
why come you can't be more like jesus
james
cause you know everybody probably
thought that james could do the same
thing jesus could do but he couldn't he
was just james
he wasn't james christ
remember the wedding banquet right jesus
turned water in a wine
right it was delicious
everybody was amazed by it right but
this is this little side note what you
might not know is with the hues right
where they got the water from was these
things called water pots and the water
pots they would set them at the door and
people would dip their hands in them
before they went inside now they were
out of wine which means the place was
full which means the water was dirty
so he took some dirty water
made it clean and acceptable and it was
the best at the banquet which is exactly
what it does for us but i'm thinking
about james
what about the next banquet
jesus probably wasn't there right
they started running out of wine
i bet everybody looked at james
hey man your brother was here last time
we ran out of wine
you just gonna stand there with your
sandals on you're not gonna make no wine
and you know how little brothers are i'm
sure everywhere jesus went james
followed him
that's what little brothers do if jesus
went there so did james i bet one time
james almost drowned
you